so name is Josh and I'm a state
scientist from stock accounts and I've
been working there for the last couple
of years at star counts we our goal is
basically trying to understand what
people were passionate about in their
real lives what do people love doing in
their spare time and we do this by
looking at social media data so if the
last couple of years we've developed a
range of tools using Python to analyze
social media data and get social media
data and this talk is really about the
the tips and tricks we've got along the
way that we just want to share with you
guys first social networks so this is a
visualization and buying argentinean
visualize data visualizer artists of
just people retweeting each other on on
our Twitter and this is actually based
on on real data in the community all I'm
trying to do is convey with this video
is that social networks are quite
difficult to understand and to get a
grasp on what is the overall picture of
what's going on what would what is the
overall picture of what's happening in
the social network so the way that we do
in a star count is we identify special
types of people on the network on the
graph and we call these stars so these
these stars could be like a traditional
famous person like an like an actor or a
pop star an artist or it could be a
online star like a blogger or vlogger or
YouTube star but it could also be an
influential institution such as a brand
or company so we call we call these
stars and we've identified these stars
across all the different social networks
and we found there to be around 200
thousands in the world across across the
major networks that means it's basically
like 200,000 sore famous entities in the
world
which is quite quite cool so we've
identified all these stars and the way
that we understand the social network is
about how people interact with with
these stars and by doing that we can
then understand people's passions on the
social network but people are really
interested interested in on a scale
that's really never seen before so this
is the data process that our base is
going to go through today so you start
off in the web with me download data and
then we do various things to it and I'm
basically just going to highlight for
four packages piping packages that we
use along the way which is pandas
twisted siphon and scikit-learn so I'm
going to start off with pandas which is
really the glue that keeps our whole
process together I'm sure many of you
are already aware of it but I'm just
going to highlight it anyway so before
pandas there was the built-in seriously
module and Python saying this in this
example I'm really simply opening up a
file iterating through it and attaching
the information to a list and this is
really incredibly slow if you do the
same thing pandas you it's slight
difference you read the whole file at
once into memory and then you operate on
it usually in a sort of vectorized
fashion which is just a hell of a lot
faster there's no reason really anymore
why you ever want to use the CSV module
the only reason which I can think of is
if your original file doesn't fit into
memory and there's this really nifty
feature in pandas where you can
basically chunk your your fault your
input file whether you reading it so you
don't have to read in hoping the time
you can read and bits at a time and then
operator little bits of time and then
iterate through the chunks so that's a
really really lifted feature
no it's not working so can you see if I
start back further yeah yeah speak I
don't think I got it working yesterday
you should to be removed no adorned with
used to working for a while okay so
perilous yet really simple SQL Ethel's
of operations like join the group is
really really quick if you use them in
the right way but not a really really
cool feature upon this is that it
supports the hdf format so the hdf
format is this how it is as optimized
for Matt and from the miracle data which
is the source of data that we use quite
a lot and its really really good for
really really large tables so in this
example in this table I've got a CSV
which originally the read time was
around half minutes and then if I
converted hdf format the real time is in
half half a second which is the
ridiculous speed up and additionally
because it's because it's not CSV it's
not being done about the way it's saving
the data is saving the data is actual
numbers when it knows is number you get
this natural size a smaller size on disk
and what's also really good about pandas
is that you can do on the flight
decompression or files and HTF files
included so you can compress your hdf
file to get it even smaller size on disk
I mean you get slightly longer read time
but it's still quite acceptable so for
right for our type of data for low data
team you guys be working with as well
this format is really really useful so
that's all I gots to serve up and us
down go to our data extraction so for us
data extraction means basically getting
data from the social network API is like
Twitter or Facebook and the way that the
api's are structured is that you can
only obtain small bits of information at
a time you can only query small bit to
the graph or small bits of the network
at a time
now if you want to understand large
large parts of the network it means
you're going to have to send off lots
and lots of queries and you're going to
have to send off lots of requests across
the whole graph and that's that's the
limiting factor in this part of the
paper pipeline this is this is the
problem which we incurred so our first
application for obtaining data was very
simple it was just sequentially going
through each query that we wanted to do
in in a sequential order one what one
after the other now it's this took ages
because it's waiting upon the server
most of time to response as the
application was I Oh bound just the
server response of taking taking a while
so the next iteration of our application
was basically just a multi-threaded the
application so each fred is doing
exactly same thing as the previous
application it's got a list of requests
that he wants to do and it's just firing
them off one by one and didn't request
again this came across we came across
some problems of this so it works at
first and show you it works at first but
then you start together getting some
problems so when you first start
increasing the threads you get a nice
linear response which is what you want
more threads more more data throughput
so you can download at a time but then
you start to get to this leveling off of
Rupert's and we found this to be at
around 200 or 300 threads so we're
getting a reasonable reasonable amount
download download of data but we need to
get more than this and we think the
reason Jesus is within the reason it's
utam maybe multiple problems one of them
is that each thread is still opening up
individual connection to the network
each thread is still doing its own its
own activity and also each thread is
still blocking itself is still pretty
stupid and blocking yourself
additionally as you probably know this
there's the Jill and Python so you're
not really getting true and paralyzation
between all the threads so the way the
way we solve this was basically to use a
synchronous asynchronous framework and
the lasing is Freya which reason
pythons twisters so sync synchronous
programming is basically what I just
described in the first application it's
when you've got one task off the other
and just executing them then you've got
parallel paralyzed will paralyze
programming so we just do all them in
parallel but at asynchronous programming
you're being a bit more clever about
things because you know they're being
blocked by the server so when you know
you're being blocked by server you go do
another task so you chop and change
between the tasks being a bit more
efficient of your CPU time they're using
instead of just waiting upon the server
to respond to you now looks like I said
sorry we use twisted to do this and
Python as a few other frameworks as well
twisted is generally useful for building
custom servers so this is a slightly
different use case than what it's
usually useful because you've got this
chopping and changing between the tasks
you're going back and forth between
tasks you're the flow of your program is
broken up quite a lot and it makes
writing asynchronous programs quite
different and difficult compared to
writing normal programs and we found
there to be quite large learning curve
with using revising these programs and
using the twisted framework so here are
just some tips for what we learnt on
what we should have done in hindsight if
anyone is going to take on a similar
project firstly I would read a book
before hand and go go through all of the
exercises which is obviously not what we
did we jumped into the deep end and I
particularly would recommend this free
book that's online but David pattukal us
and there's exercises and it's really
good and use read it and you'd get a lot
better understanding about how to use
twisted and also the bugging is quite
difficult and different to normal
programming because because like i said
before your flow is broken up quite a
lot
it's quite difficult to see where your
bugs are starting out and how they
propagate through the program so in the
end we ended up visualizing a lot of our
program using flowcharts and we found
this to be really really useful as well
so even though it's difficult the result
for us is really paid off now we've got
this source a task server that sits in
our local network the dishes are tasked
to clients in the cloud and we've got
these clients there in the clouds that
we can scale up and down each the
clients are sort of its own asynchronous
application and this allows us to
fine-tune how much bandwidth we want to
use that particular time and how much
data throughput we want to get and
Lister that this essentially allows us
to linearly scale up and down the data
throughput we want to go at any
particular time so in the end it was
really useful and there's a really good
exercise okay so next is data mining so
once we've got our data we want to do
something to it and in this section I'm
going to highlight siphon and how and
how we use siphons optimize the
particular data mining and task so I'm
just going to explain first what we were
trying to optimize and then sort of show
the iterations that we did to dr. Meiss
task so like I said before we use stars
to understand the social networks and
how people interact with these stars if
we just consider the interactions
between the stars and social network and
the users or followers then we've
basically created a bipartite graph of
the network so there's two types of
nodes and we're only considered the
interactions between the followers and
users and these influences on the
network the stars and when we now
because we've created a bipartite
network we can now start thinking of the
stars it's just basically groups they're
defined by the groups of followers to
follow them although the groups of users
to follow them and that's and that's so
we can start faking them
is basically sets once you start faking
the sets we can start doing set
operations between between different
stars to determine different things so
for example if you want to see how
similar two stars are one of us one of
the sort of things we could do is look
at the overlap of the people the
followed both of the stars or another
thing we could do is look at the
jacquard metric so the jacquard metric
is a general metric for describing
similarity between sets and it's at our
case it would be 0 when there's no
overlap of users or followers only one
when it's going when know exactly the
same set now the jack on metric is
really useful but it's really expensive
to complete this is sort of an N squared
problem so a technique to get around
this is by using a min hashing algorithm
in hashing technique so what the min
hashing techne does is you've got this
set for example here we've got a set of
stars and you basically compress this
sets into a vector of fixed length so
here I've got let vector of length 5 and
you've compressed all this information
into this fix fixed load vector and
that's a an end that takes any time so
that's cheaper than calculating the jack
of the twin sets and once you've got
this vector it's really really cheap for
you then to calculate the jacquard
between two different stars so this
vector you also call a signature so you
calculate you've got you calculate all
these signatures of all different stars
and then you to be able to work out
approximate a jacquard between these
three stars you basically identify the
values which are in the same place that
I and are also the same value so here
for 29 are in the same position and the
same value so it's free of them and then
you just divide by the length of the
vector which is five so the Jakarta miss
cater to your needs to start would be
0.6 so that's obviously a ridiculously
cheap operation just really simple
vector maps and the expenses of bit is
to create the signatures in the first
place
but that's still cheaper than directly
calculating jackals between stars or
between sets so it is only an
approximation but it's a good enough
approximation for our purposes so
there's multiple ways of calculating
these star signatures this is the data
mining calculating these signatures and
the way the week I'm going to be doing
in next few slides is basically for each
of the users on the network or the
followers we need to collect oh sorry
for each of the users on the network we
need to collect all the stars of that
person follows oh yeah thanks yep see so
the point is you can press you can press
all the so the question was here the
vectors are allowed five what happens if
106 a month and was 4 or something like
that or different lengths the points
about this technique is you can press
any set into a fixed length vector so
they're always the same length fit so in
this example we use five but that would
doubt generally just be too small so you
do something like 100 but so you can
press no matter how big the set is this
is what's really cool about Sony the
matter how much set is you can pressing
it into this thing fixed leg vector and
and then you just do the that simple
operation to get the jack off between
two sets calculating the signatures from
the stars isn't actually that difficult
the mass the the mass behind it is not
difficult it's down the time to explain
it here if anyone's interested in it
there's lots of really good resources
online how to explain it yeah so for
each of the followers are the users on
network we basically need to collect all
the stars to that person follows we then
hash in some sort of way the follower ID
and then these two pieces of information
we feed into this function will
updatestar signatures which basically
somehow creates these sausages once we
done it for all the fans so this is kind
of like the number-crunching bed that we
do
so this is our first iteration of the
code whereby we've got this edge list so
the edge list is basically a file which
just details what star each each fan or
follower follows what is user follows
and we go through this edge list and we
basically collect for each of the
followers all the stars they follow and
then we do this hashing process which is
here and then we update starting cheers
and this is sort of number crunching bit
so the important bit is that we've also
got two other things going on in this
for loop we've got an if statement
because we have to discard certain types
of followers and we've got this
dictionary lookup to convert a star ID
into an index which is later using the
matrix but that's that's not important
important bit is that I've got his foot
as if statements are boys dictionary
lookup and this as you can imagine was
incredibly slow because I'm iterating
through a CS feed line by line so our
second iteration was quite simply just
use band ice instead so we read in the
whole edge list file in once which is
about a billion lines long and also I've
converted it into hdf formats like I
mentioned before so it's a lot quicker
to read them additionally I've moods the
two statements i just spoke about and
sorts of vectorized and move them out
the full loop so I've got I've got that
if statements which I've moved at the
for loop vectorized it and I've got that
dictionary look look up we're converting
the star ID to an index and I move that
other for leap and that's basically just
a table merge when you vectorize it so
I've tried to keep a little in the for
loop is possible because that's being
executed about billion times
so just by doing a simple changes we've
got really good speed up of nearly
nearly a half so the next iteration was
to basically use siphon now siphon if
you don't know is basically like a
hybrid language between Python and see
and it gives you all the flexibility of
Python when you want it but it also
gives you the rigidity of see when you
also want it so I think it's really good
because it means you don't have to leave
this was a Python mindset but you can
sort of in a pseudo way wyd see code so
it's the same it's a superset language
the pythons nearly so we've got it's
pretty much the same spy from because
extra declarations which allow you to
declare types and a few other things so
this in this example here it's pretty
much exactly the same for loop except at
the top I've just added in own type
definitions in the siphon language to
that yet declared the types of the
inputs and outputs in the variables
between so that gave a modest fee doctor
before it was on about 11 11 minutes now
we're on about 10 minutes so it's not
know huge beat up but where you get the
really really big speed up is when you
start to remove the Python objects out
of your siphon codes so play certain
operations on Python objects in siphon
means the siphon has to communicate back
to the pipe and virtual machine and that
process as you can imagine this quite
slow so you want to pretty much
completely separate your siphon code
from reply from when it's being executed
and then it's sort of outputs back to
the pie for virtual machine at the end
so the two things that I've moved here
here you can see I've got this list on
the left hand side will follower stars
and I just instead of using a list I've
used a acra a fixed length C array I've
also got this a numpy array
which I'm declaring and I've also just
created a theory instead as well and
because I've basically released not
release I because I've taken out all the
Python code that's going to be calling
back to thee to the piping virtual
machine then you can actually release
the gel here which is really useful in
some situations although in this
situation was not useful for us so the
way you can determine what code is
slowing up your siphon program is
there's a really nifty feature on the
command line so that the tool you use is
the siphon command and you do dash a and
I basically says annotate and it outputs
a hip HTML file and then annotate your
code whereas whereas slowing it up and
what's talking about to the virtual
machine that's really useful because you
can go through and then make the changes
and speed up the code so that oh oh yeah
so the also added at the top to some
compiler directors for siphon so these
I've just added all these to improve
performance basically so the first one
is in turning off balance checking so
that's basically saying don't don't
check my indices see if it out of bounds
of vectors or raise I've also turned off
wrap arounds so that has to do with
negative indices also said you see
division instead of point from so all
these improvements had a dramatic
expedient increase compared to what we
had before so before us on 18 minutes
and as on three mirrors
so these are the all the iterations the
for the first for the top for that I've
just shown you and the last bar is the
is an iteration which I haven't shown
you which is the iteration where we've
actually optimized the number crunching
birds of the min hashing algorithm so us
doing the optimization of the min
hashing algorithm only actually gave us
the speed improvement of about minutes
which is incomparable to the other speed
improvements we got and do simple things
by using pandas and by moving to siphon
and removing the Python code which which
doesn't have that much sort of time
expense for doing those things so the
lesson learned for us was that you
shouldn't assume what's slowing up your
codes because when we first approach
this problem we basically fought the
hardcore number crunching bit of the min
hashing technique is going to be the bit
that's consuming most of the time of the
program but actually in fact it was just
all the logic that went around went
around this so you really should profile
your codes determine what's what's
slowing up your code and once was um
what's making it go slow and it was
really good nowadays as you or what's
really good is you can now we use
ipython for this sort of thing so I
Python have got two really good magic
man's like normal profile which is like
function profile and line profile which
profiles the lines and uk's and using
these two tools you can really determine
what is actually slightly up code and
what you should spend your time on
improving what's also really really cool
is that you can actually now pace siphon
codes directly into ipython and it does
all the complication steps for you so
siphon usually you have to convert the
siphon code to see and then compile the
seed library and then you can pour that
into your python module or import the
module into your python code but siphon
ipython allows you to paste siphon code
directly into the console it does all
those steps for you and then you can you
use the siphon function like you'd use
any other Python function which I find
really useful and also in the ipython
notebook you can do this dash a which is
why I was talking about before which is
annotates so if you do dash a double
dash annotate then it generates this
output and it highlights the areas which
is slowing up your code and talking back
to the piping virtual machine so it's
all really easy to do this in the
ipython console okay so that's why I got
so data mining now I'm going to talk
about data enrichment looks like it
learn